[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen sallys welt
heute gibt es mal wieder ein richtig
leckeres mittag oder abendessen
ich mache ein chicken pot pie das ist
sowas wie hühnerfrikassee aus dem großen
topf oder aus kleinen schälchen mit
einer brot kruste kann man wirklich
super toll auch vorbereiten
ich mache jetzt zuerst gleich den teig
ich nehme jetzt kein hefeteig sondern
ganz normalen tag ohne hefe und daneben
die chicken füllung könnt ihr gerne auch
abwandeln und vegetarisch zubereiten
andere gemüsesorten nehmen eben das was
euch am besten schmeckt zeigt euch mal
eben die zutaten und dann geht es gleich
los
für den teig verwende ich 500 gramm mehl
einen teelöffel salz 30 km olivenöl und
260 gramm warmes wasser und dann für die
schicken füllung 400 gramm hähnchenbrust
50 gramm butter eine zwiebel 2
knoblauchzehen 50 gramm mehl 300 gramm
gemüsebrühe 200 gramm sahne 100 gramm
jeweils tiefgefrorene möhren und ärzten
und etwas salz und pfeffer jetzt nehmt
ihr einfach zuerst das mehl salz das
wasser und das öl daraus wird jetzt ein
teig geknetet ich mache das jetzt kurz
in der küchenmaschine aber ihr könnt ihr
auch gerne mit der hand verkneten
ich gebe jetzt einfach alle zutaten
nacheinander in die schlüssel und kneten
teig zusammen
[Musik]
dann entsteht einfach so ein schöner
weißer teig den habe ich jetzt gerade so
drei minuten geknetet perfekt damit er
nicht austrocknet gebe ich ein bisschen
baktrien spray hier in die schüssel da
geht ja nicht auf daher braucht ihr nur
eine kleine schüssel und den lege ich
jetzt einfach zur seite
so kann er sich etwas ausruhen natürlich
erstmal die zwiebel und knoblauchzehe
die werden jetzt geschält und stand fein
gehackt
[Musik]
zwiebel und knoblauchzehen die brauche
ich gleich erst aber ich jetzt
geschnitten denn gleich kommt das
hähnchen dran und nach dem hähnchen
sollte er wirklich immer alles schön
reinigen
daher nimmt jetzt auch ein kunststoff
schneidebrett und einem holzbrett weil
sich das einfache reinigen lässt
und jetzt kann ich schon mal hier meinen
großen topf bzw einfach eine pfanne
erhitzen und wir sind butter eingeben
und kann da jetzt das hähnchen nehmen
und einfach in würfel schneiden
die mache ich jetzt nicht so groß
sondern eher so zwei zentimeter große
würfel und ihr könnt auch hier wenn ihr
möchtet gerne eure eigene hühnerbrühe
herstellen dann müsst ihr keine fertige
hühnerbrühe nehmen ich habe immer ein
bisschen brühe da hier geht es schneller
wenn ihr einfach hähnchenbrust nimmt
aber wenn ihr wollt könnt ihr wie gesagt
ein ganzes hinten nehmen mit gemüse im
topf waren und so auch die eigene frühe
machen dass sie auf dem grill shop mit
brot größte herz zum später verweisung
erst achtmal das ist vorgeschrieben
peter morath als würde ich hier dinge
ändern immer jeden tag das gleiche
wo sind die gläser schafft bilder die
gläser umgeräumt
dieser hatte ich eine männerkrankheit
männerkrankheit kraftvoll die ehepaare
quellen zwei schritte in jedem haushalt
oder joschka sachs in jedem haushalt
kommt es so vor
ihr wirft uns immer uns frauen immer vor
wir würden jeden tag die schränke
umräumen das stimmt gar nicht
nein vista was ich mache fotos
beschriften von außen wie bei der
apotheke
naja im tiefschlaf wo kann ich heute
stecken bevor ich das okay wenn danke
bis später wenn die butter dann
geschmolzen ist ich habe jetzt denn
herzlich auf höchster stufe sondern eher
auf mittel hoher hitze berate ich jetzt
die den würfel amt macht es in zwei
fraktionen
dann kühlt die fahne auch nicht so sehr
herunter schön rundherum anbraten und
dann einfach noch mal rausnehmen
[Musik]
jetzt einfach schön die zweite funktion
hähnchen herausnehmen perfekt dann kommt
die restliche butter hier in die pfanne
es riecht jetzt schon richtig gut darin
brat jetzt die knoblauch und zwiebel
würfeln bis sie glasig sind uns einfach
so zwei bis drei minuten
da habe ich ihn stehen die schönen rast
aromen
[Musik]
da kommt jetzt hier das mädel drauf wird
schön eingeführt also wie eine
mehlschwitze das brät man dann auch von
einer minute etwa mit an
wir nehmen nur 30 30
jetzt schön mit der gemüsebrühe
ablöschen und hier könnt ihr wenn ihr
wollt auch die gemüsebrühe zur hälfte
mit weißwein zu bereiten
konzerte sahne gleich mit dazu statt
sahne könnt ihr auch mehr nehmen gibt
den herden bisschen runter stellen
stadtpfarrer max konnopke fast stadt
saada könnt ihr natürlich auch - nehmen
seine macht natürlich ein bisschen
geschmeidiger und cremiger katar durch
den hohen fettgehalt aber mit könnt ihr
auch gerne verlassen
[Musik]
ausgelassen und dann kommt gleich das
team dazu und jetzt wirklich die hitze
reduzieren so er nur noch leicht köcheln
lassen
das haben wir erst mal die größte arbeit
erledigt
da kommt noch salz und pfeffer dazu dann
müsst ihr einfach schmeckt nach
geschmack jene fragen die salzsäure
gemüsebrühe ist ja okay stimmt und ich
will jetzt noch ein bisschen thymian aus
dem garten und dann kommt hier noch ein
bisschen anders
[Musik]
was nehme ich hier was nehmen sie es
trotzdem noch bisschen kari kraut
hähnchen curry jetzt schmeckt doch immer
gut und rosenduft thymian
das sieht gut aus die cd kräuter im
ganzen rhein die nehme ich dann gleich
wieder raus gewaschen habe ich sie auch
schon
ich las es jetzt hier noch ein bisschen
vor sich hin simon das gemüse kommt erst
zum schluss dazu hier habe ich wirklich
auf stufe 2 ich kann auch auf stufe 15
gehen und dann nämlich hier schon mal
den teig ausrollen
[Musik]
nehme ich einfach ein bisschen mehl und
rollt den teig aus das müsst ihr jetzt
nicht machen also die hauptspeise welt
so auch schon fertig sie muss nur noch
ein bisschen weiter köcheln
aber ich finde mit seiner proteste ist
schon mal fein ist was besonderes jetzt
nicht zu dünn ausrollen ist etwa 35 mm
und jetzt müsst ihr entscheiden ob ihr
das gericht in dieser großen pfanne
lassen wollte das muss natürlich eine
pfanne sein die auch in den backofen
darf also kein griff da irgendwie
schmilzt kein kunststoff griff daher bis
auch hier im bus eisen zubereitet oder
ihr nehmt einfach kleine pflänzchen die
kleinen fähnchen sehen halt süß aus vor
allem kann man schöne einzelportionen
machen oder ihr sagt eben ich nehme es
großen könnte sind so lassen
also ich mache es jetzt so ich mache
jetzt diese portionsgrößen hier gebe ich
jetzt noch das gemüse dazu ich finde
erbsen und möhren
wie passen jetzt ganz gut ihr könnt auch
frisches gemüse nehmen tk gemüse ist
aber auch immer sehr frisch weil es
einfach erntereif direkt eingefroren
wird und oftmals einfach sogar mehr
vitamine hat alles frisches gemüse weil
da weiß man immer nicht wie lange es
schon im regal liegt und da könnt ihr
echt nehmen was ihr möchtet champignons
würden auch gut passen
ich finde das macht so schön farbenfroh
sind wenn ich hier noch die kräuter
[Musik]
das gibt es hier in die gusseisen fans
ihn rein
[Musik]
zu einem halb schöpfkelle okay mir als
frau wird es jetzt schon reichen jörg
sagstetter zu zwei bändchen würde ich
okay okay meine zweifel habe darauf an
ob man noch eine vorspeise hatte oder ob
das jetzt das komplette gericht ist und
wie gut die es sind doch so nachtisch
gibt
[Musik]
jetzt stehe ich hier den teig aus
darüber läge ich ihn hier drauf da so
ein bisschen größer sein
mein größter aussteller ist leider nicht
groß genug
da hat sehe ich ihn so ein bisschen
einfach zu überlegen
perfekt daher auch wirklich nicht zu
dünn ausrollen
[Musik]
jetzt fehle ich sehe noch 1 1
damit bestreitet dann den teig aus dem
restlichen teig mache ich jetzt einfach
wieder abgibt oder flammkuchen noch
zusätzlich ist im block gebe ich das
rezept bzw
in der app dann so anderes passt das
macht die hälfte des teams dann rein
denn ansonsten habt ihr einfach ein
bisschen mit überschuss und falls ihr
übrigens keine kleinen mini gusseisen
fähnchen habt dann könnt ihr auch
einfach offen feste schälchen nehmen
also wenn er zum beispiel crème brulée
schälchen habt oder porzellan gefäße die
auch im backofen in den backofen
gestellt werden dürfen können wir das
natürlich auch benutzen oder wie gesagt
ein große eine große gusseisen fahne und
jetzt schon bestreichen und dann kommen
sie bei 200 grad in den backofen
dann probieren sie gleich
[Musik]
auch sieht es aus mit euch interview
besser schneidet ihr die decke noch ein
vor dem kochen denn ansonsten kopf wie
bei mir über jetzt ist das essen fertig
kam der wagen
guck mal versuchst versuchskaninchen die
irgendwas mach ich jetzt was ist das
überhaupt
da ist jetzt wie so ein hühner eintopf
drin also für ein shopping
hühnerfrikassee und obendrauf eine brot
kostet aber so ich weiß noch nicht wie
man es ist aber du zeigst uns okay ich
versuch's mal genau das ist cool und ist
deshalb mega heiß und der vorteil von
rettungskräften ist halt das essen
bleibt auch schön warm tätigkeit so ist
er jetzt mal so ein bisschen hier mache
ich mich als fotografin hat man gesagt
passt bitte aufmerksam macht schön auf
damit besser fotografieren
die soße schmidt schon mal sehr gut ja
es ist so rahmen also wissen vorher
nicht was er die macht will kriegen
immer nur den anruf kommen jetzt runter
geht ob wir vertreten jetzt bin ich dran
was kriegt aber nicht raus ja cannstatt
das projekt umbau der kruste
aber es ist halt nichts wissen das schon
vorher verbreitet nicht verbrennen
[Musik]
becker wollte er sagen es schmeckt nicht
aber konstituierten bringt max goldt
deshalb das ganze einfach den deckel man
also einem topfdeckel ich finde es mit
dem bruder schlug cola
meine welt gekocht hier und da kommt er
denn hin kontrolliert würdest du nach
machen ja ich mache ich versuche es
macht dennis tost dann sein bild und
verlinkt uns auf sämtliche heute nicht
ja ich maximal und poster genau sehr gut
aber es freut mich jetzt aber das
schmeckt und aus dem restlichen teig wie
gesagt ich habe zu viel teig gemacht
machen wir jetzt noch flammkuchen also
schon 20 minuten flammkuchen und dann
gibt das rezept zum nachlesen auf in
meiner app und auch seitlich ist
praktisch denn jetzt eigentlich weiter
zu essen gern wenn man mir gesagt hat
ist war ganz schnell was ich liebte es
halt wenn du dann so im prinzip zu einem
top charakter dieser eintöpfe auf dem
weihnachtsmarkt im büro und das ist ja
eigentlich so das so im prinzip so ein
besser rasch und daher
[Musik]